after the last Super Bowl there were
these retirement rumors the people were
saying Marshawn Lynch might retire how
do you think those got started I mean
you know in this game you know at this
running back position you don't you know
go down alone but I mean who they put 12
in front of you for a year you start to
think like yeah maybe I can do this in
there yeah yeah $12,000 okay well here's
your pocket watch me here's my question
and and we should we got to mention it
last Super Bowl last play you guys are
on the five-yard line everybody thinks
the move is give the ball to Marshawn
instead quarterback passes it
interception Super Bowl over people are
calling it the worst play call in the
history of Super Bowls what's your take
on that were you convinced you were
getting the ball yes I was you were
convinced you were gonna get were you
surprised when they said now we're going
a different way yeah I was but at the
same time you know I didn't been in this
position before I play a team sport and
I mean you know at the end of the day I
can't be mad at the situation mm-hmm so
I mean I'm good with it though to be
honest yeah well you
your comedy event you have had let me
ask you this question you have had your
you play such a physical role and you're
so intimidating you've had people here
the team grab at your braids and rip
them out just beautiful
do you ever think about going with
different hair bill no that's God I mean
I can't imagine anything more painful
and you have literally these grab me
ropes hanging from your head trying to
get past people you know is the giddy
you just load one really long one in the
helmet get a magician to make that for
you so the poet on you're still taking
off wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]